con grupos alzados en armas
también han recibido en esta tierra con
igual propósito
precisamente todos los colombianos que
han querido hacer presencia
buscando ese mismo resultado
resaltamos que cuba fue una del acuerdo
final de paz del 2016 entre el estado
colombiano y las fuerzas armadas
revolucionarias de colombia farc ep que
ha sido considerado un ejemplo para el
mundo entero se le puso de presente al
señor canciller bruno rodríguez que
colombia rechaza la calificación de
patrocinadora de terrorismo con la que
se ha pretendido desconocer su
compromiso con la paz de colombia y el
mundo estamos acá precisamente por todo
lo contrario
aspiramos a reanudar los diálogos con el
ejército de liberación nacional en el en
esta tierra de paz a fin de iniciar el
camino propuesto por el presidente petro
urrego de alcanzar la paz total
gracias república de cuba por su
hospitalidad nos enaltece estar acá y
gracias por la nueva acogida a los
propósitos de reconciliación que hoy y
siempre nos acompañaran la habana
república de cuba agosto 11 del 2022
muchas gracias
agradezco profundamente la visita y doy
la bienvenida a cuba al señor canciller
de la república de colombia álvaro leyva
durán así como a otros representantes
del gobierno y de la sociedad colombiana
me complace saludar y agradecer
nuevamente la visita del señor garante
de noruega del representante especial
del secretario general de las naciones
unidas para colombia y de un distinguido
miembro de la conferencia episcopal
colombiano el hecho de que esta visita
se realice a tan solo cuatro días de la
toma de posesión del presidente gustavo
petro urrego tiene una alta
significación
para relanzar y profundizar las
relaciones entre los gobiernos y los
pueblos de colombia y cuba a la que nos
unen profundos lazos culturales e
históricos
deseo agradecer al canciller le igual su
declaración y su llamado a que se ponga
fin a la ilegítima designación de cuba
como estado patrocinador del terrorismo
y usó como pretexto para ello la
presencia de la delegación de paz de la
ln que acogimos a petición del entonces
presidente juan manuel santos de ln y de
otros actores internacionales y que su
sucesor manipuló políticamente y
desconoció los actos prestados suscritos
al amparo del derecho
internacional
son incalculables los costos y las
consecuencias humanitarias que ha tenido
para cuba y el pueblo cubano dicha
inclusión infundada e injusta
seguiremos apoyando y contribuyendo de
conjunto con el reino de noruega a la
implementación del acuerdo con las farc
ep y en cuanto a las negociaciones con
el ln vemos una oportunidad para retomar
el diálogo y avanzar hacia la paz de la
manera en que lo decidan las partes
estaremos al servicio de lo que las
partes soliciten
aprovecho la ocasión para ratificar el
compromiso invariable de cuba con la paz
colombia puede contar con la voluntad de
cuba de continuar contribuyendo al logro
de la paz ansiada muchas gracias